thank you very much was a pleasure to be
in
let's see there's so much to share a
little time to talk but I'll try to talk
lesson and have more time for questions
and answers and I want to start with an
Italian story I know we do not work in
Italy but I wish we do where I work with
my Perlman international works in
conflict areas and the story goes about
a child a very disturbed child in school
and they don't know the school doesn't
know what to do with him he's sick
meeting other kids is destroying the
chairs and desks and all of that and
they finally said let's keep him busy
with a very complex puzzle and the
puzzle had oceans and forests and
mountains and all kinds of things and
they said let's just this will take a
month to fix it and they left him in the
room with the puzzle 15 minutes later
they came to check on a child and a
child had figured out a puzzle I was
like well what happened it's impossible
it took us months to figure to put this
puzzle together and they they saw that
the child had flipped the puzzle up
sides and inside out upside down and so
a very simple shape of an apple and
followed that shape and fix the puzzle
put the puzzle together
now I actually argue that the Apple are
women if you look at any crisis in the
world any crisis in the world and you
will see women are at the heart are
disproportionately impacted by that
crisis 2/3 of the most impoverished
population in the world are women 80% of
the refugees in the world are women and
children
90% of modern war casualties are women
and children
75% of which sorry are civilians 75% of
which are women and children women are
70% of the farmers in the world they are
producing 60% of the food in the world
they're earning 10% of the income and
they
less than 2% of the lands if you want to
look at the rates of HIV or illiteracy
or whatever you want to look at it
whatever crisis in the world you see
women and girls are disproportionately
impacted by the fight by the crisis but
when it comes to solutions the solutions
are what you see women and girls are
mostly on the marginal discussion if you
look at war as an example we often
discuss war from a frontline discussion
we often look at the army and the troops
and the
weapons and the military tactics and all
of these things and that's absolutely a
very good way to look at war this is one
way of looking at war and it's usually
led by men but we don't look actually is
the backline discussion which is how do
you live in war for some reason and as
someone who actually lived in war and
now works in war people forget I'm
surprised that people are always
surprised to learn that people go to
school in war and you have meals and
you'll fall in love and you'll go to
parties and go to weddings and get
divorced and all the normal life happens
within a war framework but it's fighting
and then the TV you're only seeing the
fighting the backline discussion is
usually led by women
they are literally keeping life going in
in the midst of war yet when we have
peace agreements it's usually about the
frontline discussion so it is about the
ending of fighting as opposed to the
building of peace the backline
discussion and there is a way to include
the two we don't have to choose between
women and men there is a way to include
the two but no peace can be actually
lasting and sustainable and we were just
talking earlier with someone here Bosnia
is a great example of a peace agreement
that it was about the ending of fighting
not the building of peace because you
still actually have an instability in
that country so how and women in that in
that way play a critical role so rather
than have women as a marginal discussion
you know check all the ethnic minorities
and gender minorities check check check
check we need to actually change it into
the core of the discussion there is no
way we can talk about the building of
sustainable societies sustainable
democracy sustainable economies if we
are not including women at the heart of
the discussion and this is not because I
lead women for women or that I identify
myself as a feminist or a strong woman
not at all this is actually at women for
men we argue there is no way we can have
strong Nations if we do not have strong
woman in it so that the core of the
discussion is how do you change it and
rather than seeing them on the margin we
have to see women at the core of the
discussion both at the decision-making
as well as the solutions i Sudanese
woman once told me I was in southern
Sudan and I was interviewing a woman and
I said what does peace means for you and
she looked down at her feet for a second
and she was thinking and she's like
peace means I have toenails and I was
like what does that mean she says well
for the 20-plus years of war in southern
Sudan I was kidnapped twice by the
rebels and enslaved by them which meant
that I had to carry water and ammunition
and food and I was raped by them
throughout the period of my enslavement
so I stopped every time I escaped I am
afraid of staying in one place for more
than five nights so I walked for the
whole 50 I think it's 18 years that she
said I walked and I did not sleep in one
place more than five nights a time and I
lost my toenails and since there was a
signing of a peace agreement which is
very fragile right now she said since
the signing of a peace agreement I
stayed in one place and my toenails grew
back again so peace means I have
toenails now I'm sure there's all
different age groups in here men and
women and I'm sure at least you've had a
pedicure once maybe you know so it's
like for me it's interesting also but
okay so we unless we look at peace for
my toenails perspective we are missing
out on something really major the
and how do you build sustainable peace
no as we look at conflict areas you know
from Afghanistan to Iraq and Congo and
Rwanda and all of these things now all
of these countries are categorized as
third-world as a different cultures and
all of these things we have different
ways of looking at what's happening
there and why these conflicts are
emerging there and culture for sure
comes as one of the issues that is
talked about so I want to talk a lit up
a little bit at the the point of women
and the point of culture in here and the
point of poverty when it comes to women
I argue that rather that we need to see
women as a bellwether for the directions
of the society rather than again it's
just cultural issue and let me give you
a more example of what I'm talking about
when Afghanistan came to Taliban the
first acts of violence happened against
women and the whole world said of just
Muslims it's just Afghan culture we have
nothing to do with it Afghan men also
said that you know it was just women
well eventually and this I heard the
story from an Afghan man not anybody
else said eventually we were impacted
eventually our own dressing and our own
mobility were impacted and eventually
the children were impacted and the
elders were impacted and eventually
America was impacted and eventually our
world was impacted and so just as we
deserve them arguing that we need to
look at women as the center of the
discussion we also need to look at
what's happening to women as a political
read of that direction of that nation
and so sacrificing them in the process
and we are witnessing a day in which in
Afghanistan as we are talking about
reconciliation where the Taliban women
are one of the agenda items they are not
included at the negotiating tables and
they are for effect being negotiated in
the process and this is from an advisor
who is actually part of the negotiation
he said don't worry not too much just
their mobility and their and therefore
appearances not too much you know but
but but so that's what his perspective
but I also I wonder and alcohol is for
all of us in here
you know why are we not outraged to see
that there is Afghan woman being
negotiated in front of our eyes right
now and we're all witnessing it and do
we actually need to see physical
appearances of women being stoned to be
outraged do we really need to be in that
that close to our face to be outraged
and why are we not demanding that women
are part of the negotiations not
negotiating on their behalf but them to
negotiate on what they want so so that's
one perspective is we need to look at
women as well whether for the direction
of a society Rwanda provide a very good
example where progress also starts with
women a country in which a horrible
genocide half a million women raped her
800,000 people killed in 100 days and
the one of the first investment of the
countries actually investment in the
woman it's a fascinating experience of
the of the government realizing there is
no way we can build the country and I
have had several conversations with
different government members and
everyone is like and including the
president's like why why did you invest
in women and his answer is not not
emotional it's a much more like there is
no way I can rebuild this country if I
do not include the women in it
I just cannot clean a country that was
16 years ago had bodies in the streets
you know if women are not going to be
part and partial in building it so the
same thing women are bail water for the
direction of the society violence starts
with women and progress to us with women
and that's what happens to women in
terms of legal or or or economic or any
or violence or whatever becomes a much
larger national story as opposed to a
woman's story because we when it comes
to women's story I think we have lost
our outrage about in the injustice that
happens to women there are hundreds of
thousands of women getting raped in
Congo as we speak now and we are sitting
here you know I'm not asking for
everyone to riot but there is no artery
they are one in three women gets
violated in this country and they are
not outraged that the society at large
we almost got known so how do we shift
that and we look at it it's not only a
woman story it is a nation story and
it's a societal story that's first the
second part is because it's happening to
others
we often say culture what's their
culture you know and I have to say as
someone who is from another culture and
exotic culture if you may I'm from Iraq
I'm a Muslim I can even be more exotic
if I want to tell you more details of my
family you know I knew Saddam Hussein my
father I was his pilot I grew up with
the with the guns family you know it's
it's good all of that so you can say
just say oh my god it's just a set
culture and culture and my opinion is
two things actually so let me give you
an example again of when I'm talking
about I was in Iraq II a month and a
half and I encountered two stories a
story for women a widow whose husband
was killed four years ago shot in the
head she has six children four of them
are girls
she married three out of the four girls
who are all teenagers aged 13 to 15 she
married and three all of them so I
looked at her and it's like come on I
mean I was very understand in her case I
happened to grow up with her and I just
really encountered her 20 years later in
our program and that's another story I
was like what are you doing marrying
your teenage daughter I mean come on
this is a woman-to-woman talk and she
looked at me and she said I am so poor I
really don't have money to feed them I
really don't have that money and I
believe in their education so much that
this was the pact my husband and I made
that our daughters will go to college
so it was a choice for me to marry them
and make their husband's promise that he
will send them to school or keep them
and I can't send them to school because
I really don't have money that story is
not a cultural story that story is an
economic story is a poverty story and
that when we blame it on that on the
culture then we take away any
responsibility
and ownership that we actually can do
something about it because impact is and
I would argue that 2/3 of cultural
behavior like this is poverty driven not
some rigid cultural reasons driven and
most of them are like that and that we
can do something about it it's about
giving her access to support her
daughter but then the same trip I
visited another story in which of a
teenage girl 16 her father did marry her
off at the age of 16 overnight she had
to drop out of our program and I was
like you know passionate that with the
cells like why is she now you know why
she nothing and they like look her
father's from a track she comes from a
very tribal area and they her father did
cut the deal and it was she she did get
married now as an ewok in the skin and
so I'm speaking not as a foreigner in
here as an Iraqi this happens but it's
probably 10% of the chant of the times
it happens and it's also culture and
it's also in the same framework of
culture but it's probably 10% of the
time that it happens and the way to
leave change in that regard is not
economic only because in this case it
wasn't economic is actually finding the
social entrepreneurs and looking at who
they are and how do we foster them and
how do we actually nourish them to go
about in their own communities and lead
to change and that's a different style
of leading to change but I what I
mentioned that because often when
culture is used it's a blank statement
that allows you know negotiations it
leaves the people on my side defensive
and upsets and the people in here saying
well I have nothing to do with it
because its culture and the truth is we
need to meet somewhere in between mostly
its economic discussions underlining
economic reasons for these cultural
practices and some and some are ones
that are based on some other logics
including economics that can be
changeable because nothing is set in
stone the third thing I wanted to
mention within that process of change is
you can imagine as a group called women
for women we get a lot of jokes about us
in the countries that's we work in we
memorize a joke oh women for women why
that's women from men how about men for
women yeah and we know it all it's all I
mean like yes yes yes yes but in order
to also change and I'll tell you I mean
with women we have in order to also
change we must engage men in different
ways then we have engagement in the
process and we in here I would refer to
the women's community at large so let me
tell you for shortly what women from an
international does and the learning of
what we learned why engaging men is
crucial in this process what we do is we
have safe havens for women in conflict
areas and in the midst of Wars and
post-conflict they go they come to our
program after community assessment and
poverty assessment that is based on
poverty it's a poverty driven program is
not if she's raped or not right
but within conflict areas they go
through a lot of Hell so she comes into
the program she is immediately grouped
with 25 other women and they go and
there's a social contract between us and
her well then she must attend our
program every week for an entire year
every week for an hour and a half at the
beginning and it increases to three
hours to four hours as of month number
three and she goes to two kinds of
training one is and what we call an
educational program it's access to
knowledge it's learning about her health
rights her body her nutrition her
Political Rights voting running for
election 15% of the other one this woman
they graduate run for election you know
end up political candidates in their
community but that's the same thing in
Afghanistan and all other places it's in
different ways then educational program
sending the boys and the girls school
economically education to start with
learning about the value of her
contribution as a housewife my favorite
exercise is that we compared her value
and cash income to her husband's cash
income and her labor to her husband's
labor in every single country we have
done this work and she ends up
contributing 2/3 more than the husband
brings in only
- but it's about the values not about
she's better than him whatever it's just
about appreciating the value of a woman
that this is my value in the household
so this is an educational program that
she goes through throughout the whole
year the goal of it is to have give her
safety networks to help her become a
decision maker within the household and
their community and to have her have her
access to well-being emotional and
physical well-being the second track of
the training program is a vocational and
business skills we're trying to get them
jobs access to resources is equally
important to access to knowledge so we
do market assessments we study what the
local economy needs and we teach them
vocational and business skills based on
the economic needs in that country
mostly it's farming so there's a lot of
coops that we establish in commercial
farms a lot of food processing Jam
making pickles all of these things bread
bakeries a lot of service industry we
have for example partnership with Kate
Spade that's simply outsourced to women
in Rwanda Congo I mean Bosnia and now
Afghanistan and then we have a textile
industries so it's all different things
that's its responding to the local
market this is all good she comes she
has friends she's supported she breaks
her silence she speak up she's
celebrating she's clean she's beautiful
she is now having a job and earning an
income she's graduating she's there's a
big celebration and the big question
that I get asked all the time what about
the husband's what do we do with them
so here's a couple of facts about this
what we learned a is we are not talking
to men we were meant for men at the
beginning and we are the larger women's
community but there's actually so much
attention on women and raising her
awareness and all of that but when you
go to the man is a vacuum it's a it's an
isolation and I have moved I have to
tell you I'm very personally I have
moved from someone who is sometimes
angry to compassionate a great deal of
compassion to men in the context that
I'm talking about the countries we are
working in and few things change my
and I tell you the experience of a
Congolese man whose wife and 9 year old
daughter were raped in front of him
there are patterns in rape raped woman
rarely get killed usually they're often
left alive actually and usually the rape
is always in public is never in part in
privates this is and usually the men in
their affiliated to them are forced to
see it if not participate as in
spreading their day holding their hands
or legs or whatever in this guy's case
he was forced
he literally they opened his eyes and he
was forced to see the rape of his
daughter and his wife and he escaped and
he hear the story and you can't help but
be like mad at him for God's sake I mean
she's the one who just got raid they
left the house is burnt pillaged you
know there is a daughter who's
nine-year-old is rate and their five
kids and you'll escape and we had a he
came back six months later and I had an
interview with him after six months and
I said why did you escape but he says I
couldn't face myself I was completely
emasculated I couldn't face my wife I
couldn't face my daughter I couldn't
face a community that I could not
protect them and when he escaped the
journey of his escape is very
interesting because no one talked with
him the only person that was available
for him was the priest and he came back
because the priest told him you married
her for life so you must go back to her
and when the man talks about it when she
talks about it she says when he came the
first few months was just quiet silent
and she said worse than the rape and
worse than our house being pillaged and
burned and my daughter being raped and
being homeless is that silence between
my husband and I so what triggered and
this is just one of many many many
experience no one is reaching out to man
we are cornering them just as women are
corner to being victims men are corner
to being the aggressors and the truth is
is mixed in between and so we need to
reach after men and we need to reach out
with them not with a being a finger
pointed but actually with a dialogue and
more a partnership and with compassion
when an anger and so what we developed
at Weymouth Forman is a man's training
program so it's a called leadership
training for men it approaches the
leaders in the community the pastor the
mayor the governor the Imam the military
commander it's a four weeks intensive
training for them very respectful
training there are meals there are gifts
all of these things is sort of is a bit
different appearances you know because
it's for leaders and the logic is we say
if you want to be a good leader you need
to understand what's 60 70 50 percent of
your population are asking for it's in
your best interests and I know almost
always we actually get great results
from the same from these men in
Afghanistan we trained 400 Imams
religious clerks and helped them write
their Friday sermons about women's
rights in Congo a military commander
told me said before I entered this
program every time I entered another
man's house and I had a gun and he
didn't I never thought twice about
raping his wife I always raped his wife
until I learned I got I could get HIV
and I could die and I could kill half of
my soldiers and my family no I know it's
very cruel but you know but it's yes a
simple information afraid could lead to
HIV was not provided there is no
dialogue with men
yes it's very simple but it was not
accessible and it was not provided and
this man said I stopped I abolished rape
I stopped any men who I now punish the
soldiers who rape and he talks about
very pragmatically at the beginning I
interviewed him a year later and he
moved the pragmatic heart called
argument to a very moral one actually he
sort of goes back to his wife and he
told her how much what he has done he
told her how much money he earns and she
told him how much money she earns and
after few months they saved their money
together and they moved my straw hat to
him at home and he saw the evolution of
his life and the improvement of his life
by actually treating his wife as a
partner as opposed so he does he does
evolve and so sometimes he start with a
moral argument sometimes with a
pragmatic argument sometimes with an
emotional argument but we have to have
an engaged
of discussion I'll actually start with a
story a couple of stories or a couple
one before I do that in honor of that
particularly the Yale fellowship porches
an honor to be in your company actually
as you know women for my international I
started when I was 23 years old for the
life of me I did nothing that this will
come the way it is I really just wanted
to help couple of Bosnian women I did
not know it will increase so much and it
started with 33 women in September 1993
because I celebrated my birthday in
refugee camps distributing the money and
this we are speaking now in this
November 2010 and we've helped 270,000
women distributed 89 million dollars and
impacted a million family members more
than a million family members and a lot
of people say oh like you you are living
your life look you're getting this award
this morning this is so fancy you know
all of these things and I want to give
to it is for the young generations in
here I always say I wake up every day in
my shower here's a secret it's a good
day to fly and it's a good day to die
it's a good day to fly that life is so
absolutely beautiful because it's just
there's so much learning to do every
single day and it's a good day to die
that if my question for me every single
day if I die today because you never
know when we'll each die what I have
died and a clean page with myself and
those around me and if I you know I
don't want to be a person that's like
just five more years so I can go skiing
actually I don't I have to now skiing
but you know but but you know it's like
how do you die with a with with feeling
well with living your truth now to live
your truth is not an easy thing it's
jumping literally off the cliff it's it
takes sacrifice it's the courage because
a lot of people make fun of you in the
process I know a lot of my friends it's
when it's like go get a job and buy a
car what is this mother Teresa thing and
I always told them I have a better
fashion sense than mother Teresa but
but the point is it's not necessarily
easy to do that but by god it's worth
every single second of X so to live that
dream because you know you're only
seeing the end result of it
maybe the middle result it takes a price
but it's worth it to live our truth
every single day and then the process to
be humble and always accept Corrections
because you do not have all of the
answer the answer is out there you have
some of the answers so how do we always
come at a solution from humility and my
best teachers in life with all respect
to the teachers and everywhere were
actually the women that I thought I am
helping so and with a story of no beat
you with a Congolese woman when I met
her she was 52 years old she was rate
her 20 year old as seven 20 21 year old
daughters were already in front of her
and she looked at me and she's telling
me her story and she said I never told
anybody about you that story so I was
like so what should i do should I keep
it a secret or should I tell the wall
because that's sort of what I do is tell
the world the stories and she looked at
me and she said if I can tell the whole
world my story I wait so other women
would not have to go through what I've
gone through but I can't you can you go
ahead and tell the world just not the
neighbors I heard later she was on The
Oprah Winfrey Show one of eight Oprah
Winfrey shows that we were in and God
bless Oprah because she helped us expand
but it I actually this was one of the
most humble moment in my life
you see when we talk about women's
issues in this era and this time we talk
about it as a third world women's issues
it's them I was also I mean even though
I'm from that world I was helping the
poor woman it's been and what she had
taught me in that moment of realizing
that her story connects to the other
stories of other women that she does not
know
and that her breaking her silence leaves
maybe two other women not having to go
through whatever they've gone through is
a it's a profound profound acknowledged
consciousness on her behalf that I and I
realize in a profound courage that here
I are here I was and this was only seven
years ago the educated activists women
who got a lot of these awards seven
years ago did not have the courage to
speak up and break my silence and as a
results I end up writing my memoir as
you mentioned and I end up speaking up
and now I realize it's all a full circle
and there's a foundation that we that is
not about them it is about all of us we
are this woman we are and even if you're
a man
we are these women it's all
interconnected and it is time really for
us to revive a sense of a movement for
women that includes men and women and
doing it in a different way a way that
the world will not be safe if the women
rule it but the world will be saved of
both of us contribute to making the
solutions better so thank you very much
and I look forward for hopefully a lot
of some questions
thank you so much and now we're going to
open it up for for questions and for
this part of having a conversation and
taking advantage of having st. up here
with us
so I just ask you if you have a question
to just please raise your hand and
please stand up so that also the camera
can be sure to get your question on on
taste
um I like to give you a couple of
different answer than I gave is my
although the same direction I was not
like that before I remember I want to
show you a couple of stories in that
regard well I remember when I first
started this work I would just cry I
felt guilty about everything I felt
guilty seeing water running from the
faucets really I just like how could I
have so much water and there are people
in Bosnia and Iraq my own home country
not having water it was just this and I
remember one day I it was a good day
President Clinton had honored me I was
only 25 years old and I got a
Presidential Award at the White House
one of six people you know and I didn't
even know what the Oval Office and I'm
Here I am the office I got straight A's
and it was I had a great GTV whatever
GPS GPS and whatever whatever I did
whatever it is for point whatever 3.99
something like that it was you know it
was everything was perfect
my work was doing really good we just
got a major media appearance all of that
and I remember sitting home and just
crying and I cried and I cried and I
cried it was and and my husband at the
time panics so he called the ambulance
you know sometimes men don't know
exactly how to behave but you know
though it was a very good intention he
had he was worried about me because I
couldn't stop crying and I remember the
endless for Cinco she's like is your
work okay yes I just got bizarre murder
is your school okay yeah I just got all
straight A's it's your husband we didn't
know he's the most wonderful man in the
world
so what's going on and I didn't know I
was just exhausted I was just you know
you see I'd realize that this is one of
examples of many that I had done all of
this but missed enjoying the right
so what's the point if at the end of the
day I was just exhausted in mobile I
couldn't I just cried and so what's the
point so that's was one it was story
another story I was in Congo few years
ago and I was just said this is before
we started an office in Congo about 10
years ago and I was there actually it
was in a research stage so I was just
talking to the villagers and asking them
questions it was a community thing and
at the end of the the meeting I said
thank you very much because they don't
know I was not giving anything at that
point I'm just researching so thank you
so much I really appreciate it and they
said no no thank you
and well what do you mean I haven't done
anything nothing and they said actually
just your appearance in here gives us
hope thank you and I went and reflected
and I worked a lot on that these two
stories and the connections between how
do you enjoy the ride as you do it
because you may we may not end poverty
in our lifetime or vinous but we may
choose to live in joy as we do the work
whatever work you do so that's one and
then one there is joy in here sometimes
it's as simple as having the joy to do
the work you know if they thank you for
just being here because that gives us
hope you know and this is not saying if
it could be any of us in here that's
when you have the joy inside you that by
itself sometimes does the work so that's
the second part and the third part for
God's sake they every mean I have seen
women who have gone through darkness
itself I've seen it and it's eyes and
you are one and and they yet based on
the resistance becomes the smile you see
it's that seems like an act of
resistance I will not stop smiling I
will not stop singing I will not stop
dancing one woman we have who is the
rebels in Congo cut off her leg as just
a part of a very horrible story I won't
say it is horrible besides beating and
raping or killing her husband in front
of her and connect our nine-year-old
child
forever but one of the acts of a
horrible story cut off her leg
and we have a young woman called Lisa
Shannon there was an opera few years ago
created the one for Congo women and so
asking every woman to run you know to
create a marathon and run in different
states and last this year she took it to
Congo so that's woman run and with her
prosthetic leg and and Lisa was asking
her are you sure you can you really run
and she's like I have to run
you know that's my that's my resistance
in here I have to show the world I can
run I'm continuing to run I'm not gonna
give up you know and she won if she can
run who are we not to imagine so so I
realized that the work is not in the
heroic you know the wounded hero you
know you're beautiful and it was a bit
like a martyr of your own heroism I God
knows I've been through that stage the
new stage is actually enjoy life go
dancing I love dancing and love enjoying
Allah I love beauty in life and I do
their work and it doesn't have to be
either/or
it can be both and it's actually if it's
either/or then don't do it
go and have their banking work and you
get you know but you can't have it
no more questions ah that's a good
question
again I actually it's weird it may sound
weird but let me tell you a story of an
Iraqi woman I interviewed - 16 years old
sleeping in her family's in a living
room very poor family with her other
sister and her mother and literally a
group of men stormed their home in the
middle of the night and dragged her and
her sister and kidnapped her and there
were traffickers trafficking Iraq is one
of the largest industry right now and
they were debating whether to rape her
and sell her virgin or sell her a virgin
and that was a debate and she's hearing
them debating that in the other room and
finally one of the guys came dragged her
took her to the room and he was about to
write her and she talks about that
moment where she looked at him in the
eyes and said please please please
please don't rape me because virginity
in Iraq is very important sort of ruins
your life if you're not virgin in terms
of marriage and all of that and she said
please don't rape me please please
please don't rape me don't you have a
heart and he looks at her in the eyes
and he says my heart died a long time
ago and there's something about stuff
that stories you I feel so bad for her
what she's gone through but her heart is
intact and it is his soul that is dead
and it's very sad very very very sad to
arrive that level of humanity and and
and to have even the consciousness that
you are dead soul wise but her soul is
intact she's she's injured but she's
okay
so I don't so may its part and so I
don't have an answer
what makes this person arrive that stage
you know and how can we prevent that and
how can we do the healing so that's one
aspect of the answer the second aspect
of the answer is that same woman that I
told you where they cut off her leg she
was talking she said you know I'm doing
the belt well right now she went to our
program by the time I met her she was
having $450 in her pocket she's sending
the kids to school she said but what I
worry about them when she said look I
was able to rebuild my life I'm okay I'm
okay it's okay but what I worry about is
the hatred my kids have of their fathers
and their brothers killer and I so
worried that the minute they become
teenagers they will become fighters so
there is part of it this is a healing
process is where have you lost where
where's the moment where he lost his
heart then there is a political aspect
of X and this is very strategic and is a
lot of literature written about that
from Stalin writing in brochures
ordering Russian soldiers to rape as
many German women and break their
Germanic honor to Pakistani soldiers
raping 400,000 Bangladeshi women in 71
to 20,000 balls in women in organized
rate comes by Serbian army in between 92
to 95 - it does organized that for me is
political that is we go
we pillage we're a we go with pillage we
burn and with and we rape it's part of
the territory it is a message often from
man to man as I said raped women are
rarely killed and there but they are
impregnated as sort of you know here we
are sending your women would be your
enemy inside her it is it's a much more
territorial in my opinion when that
happens so that's more when it comes a
strategy a political strategy it's
organized systematic is ordered there's
also the aspect if you talk to Congolese
right now they say would you please tell
someone that these militias are in the
bush and they're hungry and they they
don't have anything and they so they
keep on attacking it's where they eat
they write you know is where they get
all their needs basically they eat they
were they drink and they rape and so
there's this aspect of it so it there's
chance depends politically there is a
pattern of consciousness in my opinion
the second part is the pattern while I
have a UN General once said in Cambodia
don't you understand this young man who
needs some drinks some few beers and che
and get what is it I need to memorize
that course don't establishment are just
drinking some beers and getting some
beautiful young beings they call them
and this is one day you and when women's
rights for complaining about the UN
increase of prostitution in Cambodia and
so there is this whole thing well it's a
needs though it comes with the territory
and there is the whole thing of
Tolerance frankly for it is just and
there's the point of what happens when
was the last time as Rumi says when was
the last time you sang when was the last
time you danced when was the last time
you actually had their hearts in tracks
so not one answer but it depends on the
circumstances
but just wondering working in so many
different countries
how much do you find you have to change
the program at the woman go through and
how do you sort of figure out those
changes between countries like based
onthe
different cultures and different
situations you're working with um the
program is a template you notice what I
described classes education program
vocational and business skills and then
they graduate the change is mostly under
vacation skills because that's meeting
demands market demands the educational
program is actually a product of the
experiences that we work in so it's not
a foreign program as we went and studied
all these stories designed these are the
themes we want to work in what the
stories are from the women themselves so
is that and then each country then
adjusts its to make it more reasonable
to be understood within that culture
context so not radical change they have
a I call it they have the flexibility
and the ability to adjust it to make it
understood but not telling a woman you
have it's not your husband's try to beat
you it's the same no matter where it is
there's no apology about it and there's
no cultural adjustments about it either
sometimes you make that argument by
using religion and sometimes use their
argument by using human rights
convention and sometimes use the
argument by using family therapy you
know but it's the same arguments which
is not excusable there's no
justification of it so I don't you know
it's not that I actually find it amazing
that the more positive responses that we
get from these other cultures than the
negative one in Sudan I was just with my
colleagues from Sudan Afghanistan
Nigeria Congo Rwanda and Bosnia just
this last week and I spent it with them
and in Sudan they called our our leader
over there were director of office
commander of non-violent forces and
these are the government called her
commander of non-violent forces the
other one they in Nigeria they called
her the chief of all women these are
coming from men you know these are men
who are calling us so it's not honestly
but talk to the culture not in a
condescending way in a respectful way
and that's you know and that's what it
asks people when you come and lecture it
so the story I always talk about is me
interviewing a Sudanese government
official from Khartoum and I was lying
where the women women women you know if
you know me you'll see that I am on a
mission everywhere I go where are the
women where are the women were at the
women so it's a very easy job for me I
really because we are not that much
included so it's very easy to always
tell boss it's a good example where are
the women you know so the guy said you
know what please stop talking to us
until the UN team and the US team and
the European team and the delegations
come with 50 percent of their own
delegations our women don't lecture us
about women and that's the point I'm
trying to make this is not about this
way it is about here yes women in
America access to so much but gender
discrimination is still existing in this
country and you still have a lack of
political participation and a full
representation in corporate boardrooms
and in senior management's so and this
is what I'm trying to say is how I
shifted from helping these women to
understanding I actually there we're
helping each other and I need to start
with my narrative for me to be to even
be to have the honor to be in their
company so as long as we go to these
cultures like this it's just not going
to work it's just and as I'm telling you
particularly as a Muslim because the
Muslim world who is getting a lot of the
attacks it's feeling like this leave us
alone
I have friends after friends in
different countries who are saying
remember Amina Lawal in Nigeria where
they try to stone her for having a child
out of wedlock her lawyer is a friend so
I called it's like okay let's mobilize
we're trying to mobilize women in
America let's do some time and she said
please don't do anything because we
actually have more chances at stopping
it from within the system and within
Islam then if it if it comes from the
Western world because the men and the
women will become uh-huh
it would go into the defense
so it is how do we look at the culture
from a different perspective and how
frankly we step in with humility and
with also saying we don't have it
completely yet and that's when you go
into the cultural change but breathe
most recent experience in Iraq very
religious process very traditional
province I'm covering head to toe
because to respect the province I want
to work there and the mayor tells me
okay everyone every official tells me
okay but you have to meet the chief of
the tribes he must interview you and if
he gives you blessing you can work if he
doesn't so I go to him and I'm really
covering in the skies because I were the
same in Iraq but in his province I had
to cover and he's asking me who I am
what I do where I live who my father was
which tribe I belong to him all the
answers I had is wrong for him wrong
my father was it was violet Saddam
killed the people in that province I
live in America you know it's not good
no you know I don't have a tribe this is
a horrible I've like whatever he's
asking me I'm failing I know I'm like
about to be kicked out of his room and
funny I tell him look I'm just can I
just tell you what I do and at the end
of the day we're trying to help
marginalized women get stand on their
feet and get an income you know and I
skipped the educational program and I
went right to be economic one and in
that province there are 200,000 widows
and the province does not have enough
money to distribute pensions to them
five minutes of literally telling him
what I just told you said he said god
bless you and he said woman are like a
broken wing to a society and a country
could never fly if one of its wings are
broken and this is the most traditional
looking man you can ever find ever
really and he got it so if we look at
again solving people's issues which is
mostly poverty as opposed to starting
the discussion with culture because if
he said the discussion with cultures
leave alone please leave us alone
but if you start with looking at real
solutions and real economics which
address the poverty and the
infrastructure and all of that then
please work
and that's the attitude that we get is
we need tangible changes in our lives
and not just critical things of what
what without what's wrong with our
culture partners other NGOs other
organizations international bodies that
are in the countries where you're
obviously working with how is that
complimented or been an obstacle to the
work that you at when you're carrying oh
well first of all our leadership is all
national leadership I you know it we
every one hundred percent of the staff
of every country is of that country and
three-quarters of them elf in that
context that we are working and everyone
has a story themselves you know men and
women I like it so that's very important
so local ownership is crucial in my
opinion and it means it comes at a price
because they're not necessarily
excellent in a lot of management issues
or the operational issues and it means
that we actually have to segment and
augment their services and train them a
lot and build their capacity but it's
worth it
because you're building long-term
sustainability they are the ones who are
cutting a lot of materials in and a lot
of partnerships we realize a while ago
that partnership is actually part of our
work we cannot do it if we are not
partnering so today someone told me I
support hyper hyper is one of our
biggest partners and it's actually a
very nice partnership we train the women
we take them from here to there they
graduate we hand them over to heifer
heifer then it gives them a cow you know
and then they go their Partners in
Health or Doctors Without Borders our
again and another big partners where she
gets an HIV retrofire and Turlock
medicine then she comes into our program
where we're providing her social and
economic support so it's small companies
in Rwanda a higher link a good partners
you know the woman get training you
place them in that job so this you have
to look into much more seamless
relationship because we're all getting
in it in the same way the change of
partnership within the NGO sector
happens frankly with we always partnered
with each other on the ground because
that's the reality but it was one our
donor community in here saying we needed
to partner that
we started looking at it seriously and
say we have to partner and now we are at
a stage where how do we even measure the
our joint input so we can prove the
impact of our partnership both in
numbers and in facts to promote and to
learn and to habit lessons learned I
think you well three many ways out such
with yes the first appeal we often ask
or always ask for every woman in the
world a sponsor a one-woman survivor of
war by sending her twenty seven dollars
a month and exchange letters and
pictures with her for one year christmas
is coming up there is no better gift I
always say then the gift of life you
know it's a Valentine's is coming up
Mother's Day is coming up whatever it is
this is a very good gift for gift of
life I call it the second part is so
that's one thing the second part is we
have the run for Congo woman and this is
particularly for the college students in
here we have a run for Congo woman it's
actually okay you're on that great
Clementine call Clementine if you're
interested in doing a run but actually
not only for cos students is for every
woman we have mobilized thousands and
thousands of women last year reporters
and journalists run in New York City so
it is run organizing a small marathon
and I'm not a runner so I don't know it
exactly means that run how long and all
of that but run and it I raise funds and
awareness for it the third one is on
International Women's Day and this is a
non monetary supports on International
Women's Day this year we called I
started with a trip that I had with the
Rwanda and Congo and you know there's a
tension between the two countries and
women are going through the went and
going through the same similar things so
I talked to both colleagues from Rwanda
and Congo and I said how what if the
women get together in a bridge between
the two countries and they said yes we
can and it started the whole idea of
Rwanda sand cone
newswoman meeting on a literally a
bridge between their two countries and
tying their fabrics together and saying
enough is enough for this war we are
demanding peace now so we started with a
very simple effort and now and the same
day we had women in a hundred and twenty
cities eighteen countries I can't
remember how from Japan to Qatar I mean
like we have not you know women all
meeting on a bridge in their countries
and painting they're making their own
images of peace in their drawings and
they're tying their fabrics and they're
also saying enough is enough so this
year next year we're asking for two
issues again the Congo the violence in
Congo and then the one in Afghanistan in
terms of making sure that women Afghan
Center so that's we're simply really
asking organize it your issue your but
we'll give you a toolkit on how to do it
and then the last but not least and the
truth is always you know about resources
you know and this is you know so this is
so for for noble foundation that does
research and they so that two cents out
of every dollar that is given in
international aid goes to girls and
women two cents
so yes the twenty seven dollars is
incredibly helpful but it does not
necessarily it actually for a fact does
not pay the price of training a woman
and giving her a job and helping her go
through all of that so we're constantly
looking for supporters who would
actually help us get a commercial form
and and and create a co-op of four
hundred women or actually buying
shuffles for women seriously or getting
sewing machines for women and these are
all about jobs or getting textbooks for
women you know so these are more a chunk
of checks and a fund that really helps
goes into making it possible to deliver
the program because that's when he said
been partially goes to her in cash and
and some part of it's very small part of
it covers what we actually call so
that's sort of the large that the the
elephant in in every organization's room
was particularly working with women's
issues resources is very small for women
and
wasn't need for that but thank you for
asking this question and and the point
is for me run you don't a bridge $27 or
a million dollars they all work
I mean the work we do is the same
everywhere we create women's centers to
everyone not only rape victim service
it's consistent it's the same model so
there's always women centers they're
always classroom of 25 women they always
go through an educational program and
vocational skills program and they
always end up with an income training
project what does that mean what
training we're teaching them is
different from one country to another to
make it a to adjust to their local needs
it is it's it's quite thing I mean we
really I call if there is to two issues
that I am trying to highlight three
issues that I've tried to highlight in
terms of women's issues in this
particular time I call Afghanistan and
urgency as I said the flag that yes
there's an increased level of violence
and threats very serious including on
our own staff which we had to withdraw
some of them very very serious and this
woman are continuing and they're going
but it's very serious it's it's scary
last time one of our daughters she saw
on her desk you know will tell you it's
it's a constant so it's very dangerous
because the Taliban are becoming more
and more active and loud as we declare
withdrawal so that's one and in that
regard we really need at this point I
mean I was there in August there's a
it's a very interesting point of history
to notice in Afghanistan hope so I met a
woman who was promised at the to be
married at the age of six married at the
age of fifteen widowed and a single
mother at the age of 16 and and as she
and I in during the Taliban she said she
did not have anything so she was forced
to go and sell hats in the street and
they saw her and she was describing the
so she said
they beat me up with the only pair of
shoes I owned and they broke that pair
of shoes it's almost more hurtful to her
than the beaten up process is there a
breaking of the shoes you know and she
has hope she's sending her
sixteen-year-old daughter to school
she's going back to school she
determined to go to college but in the
back is he talked to women politicians
and men politicians we are scared they
are we're living a time in which Afghan
women are being negotiated away right
now in a negotiations with the Taliban
and we're all sitting so it's a very
critical point where there is hope and
there is the selling out all right
right well the government is obviously
corrupt and they don't have enough
support by the population you know and I
wouldn't to take the Taliban away from
there some of that accusation of rape
you know themselves yes it's for me is a
reflection of a larger instability of
the country that is usually reflected by
only women as I argued earlier but I
wouldn't make it an excuse and nor do I
think that you are yes it's an increase
in stability over the whole population
in general reflected mostly on women in
a physical way the rape and the Vice
so how do you develop a system to stop
right you work you empower women you
empower women so you do what you do to
help them stand on their feet so they
can speak up but you there is no way you
can stop it from our side you only can
do it by actually providing them safety
and knowledge and access to resources so
they can stand up on their feet and
that's what the you can do it and you
work with the men so they can also stop
it but there is no other way
it's an excellent question and a
question was struggling with us to be
very honest as we speak right now
because yes the the we can we can
measure we do measure from her entry
point to her exit point and six months
after her exit point but the way the
women are telling and now we introduce a
measurement to one in the community to
see what she's leading in social change
but three years after we finished with
her and what the women are telling us in
a very consistent way so now we are
trying to figure out the model of how
you deal with that is that they're
saying you are creating a force of
change on our lives brilliant and it's
measure I mean like the statistics and
all of these things are there but it's
really hard for us to hold on to that
change after we graduate and so one of
it is to continue to provide them safety
because that's what they're looking for
is actually a space sometimes but now
we're working with them on what does
that mean how can we in a different way
hold on to that change for them you know
provide them that space I don't mean
physical space sometimes it's physical
sometimes
not but how do you provide that change
where you can holding on with them one
of the things that we're experimenting
what's oh yes so the big answer is we
don't have an answer we're really
tackling this issue the second issue is
when we've been able to place them in a
place where we can find them it's much
easier could be an example we have a
contract with the local factory in
Afghanistan and it's employing 250 women
and now where it's increasing or Kate
Spade now just launched a 1,500 new in
jobs for Afghan women through us one day
is a location where we actually can find
them then you can reiterate the
knowledge and the services for them over
and over and over again it is when they
get to go back to their you know and
they get shattered into the committee
that's it's very hard for us to find so
one of the things that we did to address
it is stay in the community don't leave
a community stay five years in that
community and discipline discipline
because if you want to go and help
everyone but discipline yourself to stay
five years so you are at least
persistent in that change and even
though they have graduated from the
program they can still come to you but
we it's not a fixed model as in they get
this training with strangers and that's
what we are actually in the middle of
looking at it but I do want to take
advantage of talking about Afghanistan
in both sides because I recently was
there as I said and and talking about
the hope so I met one eight years ago I
met I was in Afghanistan and there was a
line in front of our office and always
there's a line in front of our house not
the only and about all the countries the
hardest thing to do is to tell a woman
sorry we don't have enough supporters
for you because it's really hard so
she's and there was a girl and the girl
was I went to her and I said honey this
is for women not for girls and she says
I'm saying but let me help you find a
children's organization no I'm staying
well you know can I give you money
no I'm saying what do you want to do I
want to become
teacher how about chocolate no I'm
saying I swear whatever I talk to her
I'm saying and I end up talking with her
a bit more and there's nothing really
nothing it was a crowd of woman and
there's a girl in the middle of it and
attracted my attention that's it and I
learned that she was an orphan and that
her name is Dana which is my name and so
I obviously it's a trigger intrigued by
it this is it could have been her I
could have been that saying that you
know it's just a fluke of luck or
blessing or whatever it is that I grew
up in a family that was a nice family
very nice family so I pay attention to
her and we realize that she's an orphan
and living in unfriendly circumstances
with her guardian of very poor very very
poor and we tried to find her a place
and which we did but her guardian took
her out and made her a maid
as a child she was like eight nine years
old made her a maid but again one of so
she wants to school for a year under our
supervision she did very well but her
guardian took her out and made her a
maid and again in the woman who in the
house as she was working with said known
only have a lot more potential so she
takes her to an orphanage and she puts
her in an orphanage and we don't know
where's a novice we can't find her until
few years later one of my colleagues
watching TV and she sees Dana playing
the flute on Afghan national TV and she
calls me says Dana we thought we call
her little Zeynep is playing the flute
on TV and she stays in my mind oh yeah I
can't connect with her I she's in an
orphanage and last August and last
August I was in Afghanistan in Kabul and
went to find Zeynep little Zeynep maybe
I went to find myself actually I don't
know and went to the orphanage and she
jumps on me and we're hugging and crying
I don't have children but it's like you
know it's a very beautiful moment for me
and I learned that she's what school and
the orphanage not only she learned I had
to play the fluid but she's fluent in
English and in computer skills but she
went to school I don't I don't
next season's cool but she's she's was
very proud that she's good in computer
and in English and she wants to be a
psychologist and I have to suppose on
this because usually when you asked
children in different countries what you
want to do and believe me as someone
from Iraq we had handful of
psychologists in the whole country maybe
six though I wish that we get sent an
army of psychologists to Iraq nuts and
army of weapons you know so the fact
that she wants to be a psychologist in
Afghanistan a culture that it's not
necessary at New York City where
everyone goes to there are people you
know it's a you know it's really I mean
like there's not that that's not so and
access so it was very specific she had
thought about it she said she wants to
do that and so now with the help of mr.
mrs. Hyland who are here with us we're
trying to find her a scholarship to come
to America and to study and finish her
schooling and we're hoping that one day
she can come to yell as well and finish
her schooling and become the first
psychologist of Afghanistan inshallah